in honor of Wonderwoman 75th anniversary
DC Universe Online is launching at the
summer of wonder including open episodes
sweepstakes and more and we've got an
exclusive first look at the kickoff of
their celebration of 75 years of Wonder
Woman check it out
she's a girl among all these dudes and
she's like kicking but she's really
awesome and she's very fun to read the
lasso of truth is really cool the fact
that she can fly superstring she is
perfect for the past 75 years she's been
the most recognizable female comic book
character she's had her own stories told
continuously in a variety of formats
from comic books to TV series to films
and of course in videogames like DC
Universe Online Rowling I must warn you
Athena my friends are very strong
well it's good like a year like you're
exerting yourself you've got the
Minotaur and trying to push them over
he's heavy
looking the one of the big one that
worse okay Wonder Woman means well she's
a gift to me she's been a gift because I
was given a job to give her voice and
I've been doing it for about 16 years
and to be able to be associated with a
character that is so beloved not just in
this country but throughout the world
that is a present
it was bestowed on me and so I feel an
obligation to do her justice part in the
poem and to represent her well
Hera give me strength excellent
that's great I'm sad give it your
thoughts good Wonder Woman is
fascinating because her appearance in
October of 1941 predates Pearl Harbor
but here you have this incredibly
patriotic character who's going to soon
be battling Nazi saboteurs across the
country the fact that she's an Amazon
she's an outsider and she's looking at
our society our beliefs almost with this
innocent childlike quality she doesn't
necessarily understand it all because
she's been raised in a virtual utopia no
violence there's very little death she's
always there she's always protective
she's never bitter she's never mean
personally she's always been there for
the people that are close to them
woman absences everybody so that's a
gift to have men and women come up to
your children older people younger
people who love the character we wanted
that Wonder Woman that you think of when
you when you're just sitting there you
close your eyes you imagine Wonder Woman
that's who you get to be with in our
game Wonder Woman is important to the
game but she's also very important to me
personally growing up I felt like it was
a hero I could identify with she wasn't
like a derivative of another character
she was her own hero and she was very
confident with her own strength which
helped me wanted to be confident with
mine so one of the DLCs that I was most
excited to work on was sons of Trigon
because that's the one where that
relationship really developed with
Searcy this this anger and like
resentment they have for each other and
one of the first times I got to really
sit down and work with Susan Eisenberg
by the Thunderbolts of Zeus I am
thrilled to be celebrating Wonder
Woman's 75th anniversary I'm really
excited to be celebrating the 75th
anniversary with Susan and Jack I'm a
part of that seventy-five years we all
are that's amazing I am so proud and
thrilled and delighted to be part of
Wonder Woman 75th anniversary
celebration great Hera
that's it for now but get ready for the
start of summer of wonder on July 20th
and you guys we are going to be covering
everything going on at San Diego
comic-con starting this Thursday see you
tomorrow